[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
a lot of numbers for you this morning
starting of course with 70. 70 years
since the queen's accession in bingo
lingo that three score and 10 to her
majesty who this morning knocks
everybody else off the front pages with
some pretty adroit succession planning
it's also smooth over at number 10 where
it's man alive five of the prime
minister's top aides resigned this week
the chairman of the tories back bench
group the 1922 committee is said to be
holding a jump and jive that is 35
letters of no confidence in mr johnson
but to trigger a ballot his committee
needs to clean the floor 54 letters well
that's just the tory party bingo but the
figures that will probably determine the
prime minister's future are coming from
next door at legs 11 downing street in a
typical household the energy costs are
700 pounds up after tax income 500
pounds down and inflation not so lucky
seven percent the question being asked
this morning is how long does the prime
minister have in downing street are his
days numbers
let's see what i guess think it all adds
up to
it's been another week of turmoil for
number ten with surely yet another to
come not much fun for ministers to come
on and defend their boss but i am
pleased to say we'll be joined by
business secretary quasi quarten
we'll get the view from labour with
shadow foreign secretary david lammy
the first minister of northern ireland
paul given resigned this week over
post-brexit trading arrangements
plunging politics there into fresh chaos
and adding yet another thing for the
prime minister here to worry about the
leader of the democratic unionist party
sir jeffrey donaldson has been unusually
fierce in his criticism of the prime
minister in an extended interview for
this program with our senior island
correspondent david blevins
well one man who knows what it's like to
feel extreme
pressure while holding one of the top
jobs in number 10 is gavin barwell lord
barwell who was chief of staff to
theresa may during some of her most
tempestuous brexit years
with steve barkley now taking the job
we'll ask him how people will be feeling
behind that most famous of black doors
meanwhile the international standoff
over ukraine rumbles on unnerving
unnervingly they've been both tough talk
and called for de-escalation from world
leaders
but what does vladimir putin think and
what does he want we'll ask mikhail
kordakovsky once
russia's richest oligarch and now living
in exile here in london
but first i'm joined by business
secretary quasi quatting good morning
secretary of state
um let's start with those numbers um we
now know that the typical household is
going to have to pay 700 pounds more
each year for their heating
while they take home 500 pounds less
mr sumat sunak has promised 350 pounds
back the majority of which is alone by
the way
now all that before seven percent
inflation kicks in you're an economic
historian so we all know you can add up
um where's the missing 850 quid per
household going to come from so we've
said very clearly
that
this is a difficult
place to be
we know that this is a global challenge
because
you've seen a quadrupling four times uh
increase in gas prices and i was very
clear at the beginning of the winter in
september that the price cap
would protect people it has protected
people you're right to say there's been
an increase
in the price cap but i was very pleased
to see that the chance for the exchequer
last week came up with the measure
the set of measures that you've
described now the 200 pounds i think is
a real help and it's not just the 200
pounds it's 150 off uh council tax but
there are other measures as well there's
the warm home discount uh which has been
increased and is now applying not only
to two million people but to three
million people 100 so there is 150
pounds it all adds up
um but you're quite right to say 850
pound gap your average typical household
is going to find themselves
what 50 to 100 pounds short every month
it's going to be a very difficult time
and i've maintained that uh throughout
the last few months that's why we've got
the price cap we're trying to shield
people from global price increases it's
not something that we can do up 100
percent
but i think the ma the package of
measures that the chancellor announced
last week
uh were were impressive and uh extensive
as well well i don't think when you say
impressive it's not that impressive to
the average household to be told
it's difficult i mean
forgive me
that people are going to be saying is
that all you've got it's going to be
difficult well look i think that people
understand that this is a global issue
so gas prices have gone up four times
and clearly what's happened is that the
price the retail price
hasn't gone up four pounds and that's
because four times then that's because
uh of the energy price cap we're the
only uh country in europe that has a
price cap that's shielding uh consumers
and
uh we will continue to do so yeah but
since you brought it up in france i
think that the rise is four percent i
mean
it's 54 percent here i mean what have
the french got that we don't have so the
first maybe the french exposed to um
higher prices they've also managed to
scare
a lot of um people who are trying to
invest in france we've got the highest
in with investment uh of any of any
country in europe that's relevant trevor
to this whole
equation that we're we're
securing uh jobs hundreds of thousands
of jobs we've got a very very low
unemployment rate but you're right to
say that the cost of uh living is an
issue look um
let's talk about the actual difficulties
that people are going to face um how is
this uh thing with the uh
the loans on energy going to work
what happens if um i
in two years time when you start you're
supposed to start paying it back 40 quid
a year
i set up my own home for the first time
in two years because i'm a first-year
student or i've been separated from my
spouse does that mean i'll still be
paying the 40 pounds
uplift but i won't have benefited from
the um
from from the loan will i no so you'll
get people who get uh the upfront uh
loan will be paying it over five years
um and that's uh that's how it's going
to be repaid over five years uh it's a
smoothie what if i haven't had the
upfront load it's my question really
that's what somebody's gonna be yeah you
will be paying um your energy prices
according to the according to the price
cap according to what the price cap will
be at that but would you but would you
still be paying the 40 pounds a month
a year sorry bank button 40 pounds a
year would you be paying that back so
even if you hadn't had it so as i said
you'll be paying according to the price
cap according to what your supplier
but that's a different kind of thing
it's important that's an answer to a
different question if if i haven't had
the benefit
of the uh
of the 200 pounds will i subsequently
still be expected to pay 40 pounds extra
on my bills what i'm trying to say is
that the way in which the money is
recouped on the may be reflected in the
price cap and my department is working
with treasury to work out the exact
process how that money is uh
but that's the principle so what you're
going to try and do is
when you get to that point fix it but
you haven't really closed the the the
principle has been established that
where um the treasury is going to give
200 pounds and then the the money will
be recouped over five years
but of course i can't predict you i
can't tell you what this is what what
the price will be in five years time but
it will be recouped off that all right
look there's there's a there's a
separate uh point here really which is
uh it's it's one about fairness really
isn't it
you're going to be treating millionaire
homeowners
in exactly the same way as people who
rent a studio apartment we know that um
the highest
10
highest 10 of income earners
pay about 4 in energy costs the lowest
10
pay 13
um
but you're giving them the same amount
of money i don't think that's quite
right in fact actually the the way that
we would have given them the same amount
of money is if we'd adopted the labor uh
policy of uh essentially just removing
the vat that would have given everyone
uh regardless of their income the same
uh amount uh proportion back everybody's
still getting so quick so where where we
are here and you mentioned it earlier is
that we've of course got the 150 pounds
uh discount off the council tax which
relates to cap bands a to d
now you'll appreciate that you know the
highest uh income earners in the country
are not living in a to d properties
generally they're living in uh higher
bands so they're not going to get 150
pounds so it's not right to say uh that
people are getting this oh well let well
let's talk about that council tax thing
because um
the banding is based on historic
property values that's right 1988
which means that people in london who
live in homes worth more than half a
million
are in the same band and will get the
same uh help as people
who live elsewhere in the country in
homes worth
less than half of that i.e people in
uh
wealthy people in london homes will get
the same money as poorer people uh in in
the rest of the country how's that
working again that's not quite right i
mean you're quite right to say that the
council tax refuse is refers back to
1991 i think prices but um
that's a general issue with the council
tax what this uh rebate this discount
does is it targets people at bands a to
d
so
wherever they're living these are not
people living in the most lavish homes
or the most affluent people
in the in their boroughs and i think
they're getting uh reasonable support
it's not uh going to pay for everything
but i think it is a step forward in
trying to
uh alleviate the pressure that many
people face all right i just want to
give you the chance to clarify because
you mentioned it a moment ago
the chancellor
is not going to consider cutting vat on
fuel that's off the table well i was
just mentioning the fact that the v80
off fuel
is a
it's a benefit that is quite regressive
actually because rich people will
benefit just as much as people on lower
incomes that's not something which uh
the conservative party or the chancellor
want to do they want to have more
progressive taxes
so that people who
can who need the money uh are the ones
who get it so he's definitely not gonna
do it that's up to the chancellor i
have uh spoken to him and that's not uh
something that he's considering he had a
very full package last week i was
there in the house for 70 minutes i
listened to it very carefully i agreed
with all of it um and i think it's a
it's a good set of measures that he's
brought in i talked to your colleague
liz trust last week and i did put it to
her that um the cut in household income
equates to about 12 weeks shopping if
you uh shop in waitrose um and i i
worked out this week that it's actually
more like 20 weeks if you shop at aldi
um why are you punishing the poor by
forcing them to choose between heating
and eating well as i've tried to say
all the measures most of the measures of
the transfer announced last week with
regard to energy bills
are very strongly targeted at people
uh on lower incomes we haven't uh talked
yeah but they've already they're losing
lots and lots of money out of this
network we haven't we haven't uh talked
about uh the warm home discount i
mentioned that you seem to dismiss that
but i think that's significant i think
that the uh 350 pounds package is
significant and also if you look at the
bigger picture we are the fastest
growing economy in the g7 people uh are
not facing unemployment and you've got
to remember that at the middle of covert
in 2020 people were prophesying that
there'd be millions and millions of
people unemployed and thanks to the
interventions that the chancellor made
we avoided that so i think the prospects
the economical aspects challenging are
are actually promising as well all right
the reason i didn't mention the warm
homes discounts is it's been there for
years yeah but it's it's it's not new
but but all your there's
who are going to benefit from it is
going to increase 15 that's a million
more people all right let's talk about
um
this is a politics show and that's so
let's talk about politics uh so charles
walker one of the prime minister's most
loyal supporters uh is in the observer
this morning saying it's inevitable
that's his word that tory mps will
remove the prime minister from office
if charles walker's saying that um
game's up really isn't it well i don't
know where charles walker's um where
he's coming from i didn't see what he's
seeing i think he's a good
uh vice chairman of the knights too
well you know he's entitled to his view
as i'm entitled to mine he's talking to
his colleagues and i have to say trevor
you know this i mean lots and lots of
people have said things are inevitable
and they never happened
over the last few years and i just want
to wait and see i'm very focused on
delivering the agenda as is the prime
minister i spoke to him earlier in the
weekend
and we're very focused on making sure
that we have a strong economic recovery
that we've dealt uh with the american
virus and also with
the the coveted pandemic that we're
creating jobs we're bringing in
investment into the uk those are the
things we're focused on as well as
dealing with international challenges as
we're seeing in the ukraine and with
russia so that's what we're focused on
charles walker was also elected on the
manifesto that we all were elected on
2019 and i'm sure he's 100 focused on
delivering on that manifesto
so um
uh
as we're on the issue of ukraine are you
one of the people to whom the prime
minister has said it is reported this
morning that it will take him a tank
division to drag him out of number 10
and if you were were you one of the
people who might have said to him
prime minister shouldn't you be worrying
about the tank divisions threatening
ukraine rather than i think he's
worrying about uh the tank division
let's face it did he say that
no i haven't mentioned uh he didn't
mention that at all i had a very uh good
conversation with him we were focusing
on uh jobs we're talking about economic
recovery uh we did mention
uh ukraine but i don't recognize uh the
language that's been reported
yeah but we're talking about this and um
in a way it's all of mr uh johnson's own
doing isn't it isn't it i mean uh mr
cynic and mr javid have both said this
week that they would not have used the
words
that he used about sakir stama let's um
start this bit by just asking me asking
you would you have used those words i
think it's entirely legitimate would you
have to use that oh you would have used
those it depends what the context was i
mean in that context would you have used
that words
in that context i think it was perfectly
reasonable to mention the fact uh that
zakir had apologized sakir himself
apologized on behalf of the uh of the
organization that he led about the fact
that they failed uh to prosecute uh
jimmy seville so the fact that he
apologized suggests that he does at some
level bear some responsibility now i
don't appreciate himself the day after
he said that's not what i meant
are you sure you want to say that you
would have used those words no what i'm
trying to say is that it's about
leadership it's about accountability
secure apologized and so that was
something that was absolutely in scope
now i'm not saying that he had a
personal blame he didn't uh and we've
been very clear about that and the prime
minister clarified that position as well
but i think in the in the cup and thrust
of uh debate uh when people are talking
about leadership and accountability um
bringing up something that serbia
himself apologized for uh is seems
reasonable would it have been good
leadership if uh he had taken the advice
of his
now former head of policy manira murder
and apologized for giving the impression
which i have to confess pretty much
everybody else in the country took that
he was talking about secure himself i
think he clarified uh what he said but
he was very clear that uh zakir did not
have a personal responsibility was not
his fault personally should he but zakir
did apologize on behalf of the
organization that he led and that's what
leadership should be the prime minister
have apologized i think the prime
minister was absolutely right to clarify
uh his position manila mirza has her
position and subsequently uh left left
her roll
um
steve barkley
he's now the prime minister's new chief
of staff he's already a minister
he's got his constituency um
tempted to ask you know if he's got
enough time now to be chief yourself
what have you been doing with all this
spare time up until now i think what
steve's doing i mean it's a great
appointment by the way i've worked with
steve in government for four years now
and he's one of the most honest most
rigorous
uh most collegiate ministers we have
and i think it's absolutely right that
we should try and get the cabinet office
and number 10 uh working more cohesively
together and that's what sugray said in
her report she said that there were
leadership structures that weren't that
were opaque that was it was very
difficult to see where the
accountability was and by appointing uh
steve i think the prime minister is
recognizing that and he's trying to
combine
uh the number 10 operation with that of
the cabinet office and as you know steve
is uh head of the cabinet office in his
role as uh cdl chancellor the duchy of
lancaster um uh secretary of state i'm
looking back over you know what we what
we've discussed and what you're saying
to me is charles walker
well who knows what
what he's on when he says this this
stuff about the
the prime minister having to go uh you
don't agree with mr sunek and to javid
that prime minister that they shouldn't
have used those words uh you don't think
he should uh apologize um
the prime minister's friend donald trump
once said that he could stand in the
middle of fifth avenue
shoot somebody and he wouldn't lose
voters what does boris johnson have to
do for you to call time it's premier
league what donald trump said was
completely irresponsible it's not
comparable you're mixing uh these things
up which they shouldn't they're very
different prime ministers are
accountable uh with the ministerial code
he's also ultimately accountable to the
electorate and people forget this but he
won a majority as the leader of the
party of 80. uh he has a mandate for the
rest of this parliament and my job as a
minister in the government is to make
sure that we deliver on that mandate and
work hard for leveling up work hard to
increase jobs to increase investment in
this economy and that's largely what is
happening
at the moment and i'm very very focused
on on for the next two years delivering
on that agenda and you absolutely do not
agree with the stance which is
apparently being taken by your colleague
mr sunak who
is essentially distancing himself from
what the prime minister's been saying
this week i was with rishi sanak in the
house of commons for nearly an hour and
a half last week and he unveiled a
really good set of measures to help
people no but i'm talking about what he
said
so why i'm mentioning that is that we're
working together uh we're 100
uh behind the prime minister and we want
to deliver on the mandate that we were
elected on successfully
in 2019
secretary state thank you very much
indeed for your time this morning
now let's get labour's take on all that
from the shadow foreign secretary david
lammy joins us from central london
now um
morning mr lammy uh
so far let's talk about your area of
responsibility first if we may so far
you've essentially supported the
government on its ukraine policy but
you've criticized them for being
distracted by domestic politics and
we'll come to all that in a minute
if they were not so distracted what more
would you want them to be doing
well look of course it's important that
we stand up to russian aggression
abroad
and in central europe but it's hugely
important that we deal with russian
aggression in our own country and
we have been calling now for months and
months for the government to implement
the russia report that our intelligence
select committee
reported on
we have no register of overseas property
250 000 properties in london owned by
overseas entities
they haven't dealt with the computer
misuse act why
they have changed electoral law
to allow limitless donations to
political parties it's hard to
understand they've taken
about five million pounds worth of
donations from russian linked donors
they should give that money back
and so we've been saying that we have to
deal with the dirty money that's
circulating in london london becoming
the laundromat of the world and
embarrassingly president biden conveying
concern
that the sanctions regime that we needed
is comp is compromised because the
government's refusal to deal with that
dirty money problem
okay i i want to come to that actually
because you've issued a press release
and you've named some of the individuals
that you think
are behind this kind of money but before
we come to that can i just ask you about
ukraine itself
liz trusts when i spoke to her last week
said clearly that the uk should arm a
resistance movement in ukraine if there
is a russian takeover would you agree
with that
well look i was
in kiev just about a month ago now
and it was clear that
in kiev they were hugely supportive of
the work that we've been doing through
operation orbital with their armed
services helping them to train
but of course if it is the case that
russia chooses to
incur or invade the country
they will need support and it's
absolutely right that we
support the ukrainians in that defensive
posture because that's the situation
that they will be in
so does that mean that labor would
support sending money and arms to a
ukraine
resistance movement were there to be a
russian takeover
well look this is the ukrainian army
that we've been working with now since
2014 let's remember that
uh because of the annexing of crimea and
because of that incursion into
the dom pass and the separatist fighting
that's going on already within the
country uh we have been working uh with
those armed forces training them and
supporting them and
nato allies of course want to ensure
that they can protect the integrity of
their country the sovereignty of their
country we said that this would be a
very very bloody battle indeed already
14 000
people have died because of that
incursion and just outside the cathedral
there is a wall of remembrance for all
of those young men and women that have
lost their lives uh we tend to forget
that they have already been
experiencing this conflict and of course
we must
support them if there is to be a battle
ahead
that that okay so you would support
arming
uh
a resistance movement
resisting russian aggression absolutely
thank you now um
you obviously do want to talk about the
issue of
russian what you call dirty money in
london just to get one thing clear if um
any labour politician or organization
were to be found taking money from putin
or any of his associates you'd want uh
them to give that money back or be
thrown out of the labour party
i think at this time it's incumbent for
all of us
to be clear about the dangers of
plutocrats kleptocrats and money
laundering in our country the tituation
changed dramatically after
2014
and we should all be cognizant of that
situation it's against that backdrop
that we have challenged the government
on the donations that they have received
yeah i'd like to come to that in a
second i just want to ask you about
something that's actually in your
control which is linked to the labour
party government
but i want to ask you about something
that you can actually
make a decision about which is would
labor throw out anybody who took
uh putin or putin associated money
well what we've asked for for the
conservatives is to give the money back
and yes no no i just asked you about the
labour party i'm going to ask you about
the conservatives but i want to ask you
about labor party
yes and i'm responding to you trevor and
i'm saying
that if that is the case the money
should be given back
okay thank you all right well let's
let's talk about the tories and you've
um issued press release today and i i
will look at one of some of the people
that you name in your release um
one of them is uh the ukrainian born
selenade blavatnik who is the united
kingdom's richest man
and is you say an example of what you
call and i'm quoting here from your
release the widespread presence of
suspect russian money in the uk and you
want the conservatives uh him to
conservatives to give back the 145 000
pounds he's given them in the last 10
years
look the case is this that we have
individuals in our country who often
have dual nationality
many of those individuals made money
under
putin's regime and if you go back upon
the breakup of the soviet union taking
over what were previously national
industries the times today is reporting
the sons and daughters of people linked
to putin
buying property
here in london it's against that
backdrop that it's wrong to change our
election law to say that you can have
limitless donations of course it's
important that we are completely above
board and any money associated with
vladimir putin in his regime should be
given back
does that mean selena blavatnik should
give back should be given back his 145
000 pounds that this comes from your
release
give him give him the money back that's
what we've said
okay uh
should um
oxford university also gave back the 75
million pounds he gave them in 2010 and
should your own alma mater have harvard
university give back the 250 million
dollars it received from him in the past
decade if this is dirty money
i think we should make a distinction
between political donations to our party
that is the distinction that was made in
the russia report that is the
distinction that was made by the senate
in their foreign affairs committee
report where they were concerned about
the influence of that money on political
decisions of the day so what we're
talking about are political donations
and we must have a system that's
accountable that's transparent and that
is above board that is the basis on
which we are asking the government to
deal with dirty money but that's not
just the labor government doing that our
own uh intelligence select committee
asked the government to do this and
there's a range of things that i've set
out overseas property uh how we change
uh companies house uh and our people how
we deal with espionage how we deal with
the golden visas that are okay
because
okay
because you stress the political uh
donations
let's just try one one more uh blavatnik
has given money to barack obama hillary
clinton kamala harris and joe biden will
you be telling them that they should all
be giving them that money back
trevor i i don't think that those
individuals need
advice from me and you know that my
concern is the politics of this country
barack obama shouldn't dirty his own
position where money from my concern is
the situation on our eastern borders my
concern is dirty money here in london
that's the concern
of joe biden it's the concern of our
intelligence committee and that is where
rachel reeves and i uh this morning have
said the conservatives should give that
money back
all right okay let's just return to um
as it were normal politics if if that
phrase can be used about what's going on
right now um
you your leader says he really can't
wait for the prime minister to fall and
you think it's your patriotic duty to
make that happen
um
it seems that there are a lot of tories
who would like to vote for a
uh no confidence motion um
is labor anywhere nearer getting to a
place where it can move that no
confidence motion or is it waiting for
back bench tories to do the job
the number one issue here trevor is that
the prime minister should resign
you know and there's a lot of history
that he could look at he says he's a
great historian chamberlain resigned
when he could not form a national unity
government eden resigned after suez
theresa may indicated she would resign
after a disastrous general election and
david cameron resigned after the
referendum because of the numbers the
majority that the conservatives have
this is an issue for conservative
backbenchers and of course you've seen
many of them indicating that the time
has come for him to step down uh a vote
of confidence well why not give them the
opportunity to vote in the government
and of course labor of course labour
have no confidence in the government but
this is an issue now about boris johnson
and his fitness to govern
allies
i get that enemies are laughing at him
the public are ashamed i get all the
adventures are have left evidence it's
on that basis that he should step down
trevor i get all that but why aren't you
giving
the
conservative backbenchers and the other
parties the opportunity to vote for that
to happen
[Music]
that's leadership isn't it you know that
you know on the numbers
that we have in the commons within the
opposition we can't make that happen and
that was sealed in the general election
and the result that we have so this is a
matter for the 1922 committee and it's
about boris johnson individually
a confidence measure in the government i
suspect would fail uh if we were to
bring it to the to the floor of the
house at this stage
because it would take conservative
backbenchers voting for it to bring him
down
david lamey thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning
thank you
now
don't forget the great debate returns
tomorrow night
with broke britain can you afford the
cost of living crisis we want you to
join our virtual audience and share your
experiences and the decisions you're
having to make
to make ends meet if you want to get
involved email the great debate at sky
dot uk and tune in at 9 pm tomorrow
i'll be there anyway
now
drp leader sir jeffrey donaldson has
urged boris johnson to prioritize the
political crisis in northern ireland
over controversies in downing street
earlier this week northern ireland's
first minister resigned over the
government's failure to address unionist
concerns about the brexit border in the
irish sea
city donaldson said the fallout from
lockdown parties number 10 was making it
difficult for the prime minister to
focus
he's been speaking to our senior ireland
correspondent david blevins
boris johnson promised your party there
would never be a border in the irish sea
then he promised to remove that border
why do you still trust him at all
well the prime minister did let us down
and let us down badly and at the
conservative party conference this year
i met the prime minister he apologized
to me the problem david is that we've
had a lot of words about triggering
article 16 which the protocol
allows the government to do in
circumstances whether it's economic or
societal or political harm caused by the
protocol and yet we haven't had any
action i've asked for a commitment that
if we don't get agreement article 16
will be triggered and the uk government
will take unilateral action to
honor the commitment the prime minister
gave to honor the commitment the
government gave at the restoration of
our devolved institutions that they
would take steps to introduce
legislation to protect northern
ireland's place within the uk and they
have failed to do that that is why i
have acted now so you've acted the
agriculture minister from your party
halted checks we know that's not subject
to judicial review but if a minister in
the devolved government had the power to
halt brexit checks
how did westminster have the power to
remove northern ireland from the
european union in the first place well
because the people of the united kingdom
voted for all of the united kingdom to
leave the european union but doesn't
that mean the government of the united
kingdom alone has the power to either
halt or continue brexit checks i believe
that the government of the united
kingdom does have the power under
article 16 of the protocol to take
unilateral action to protect northern
ireland's place within the uk and to
protect the integrity of the uk internal
market and i'm saying to them very
clearly that if and i want to see
political stability in northern ireland
david i've worked for decades for
political stability that is my objective
but we can't have political stability
when the concerns of unionists are being
completely ignored when this protocol is
harming our relationship with the rest
of the uk and the government is failing
to act
when do you want to see this dormant
election and if the dup
doesn't win that election are you
prepared to nominate a deputy first
minister and see a shin fian first
minister
well it is a matter for the secretary of
state for northern ireland to decide the
timing of the election
we will be ready to take our case to the
people as soon as that election is
called in terms of the outcome of the
election david i want unionism to win i
am not contemplating
defeat
at the hands of sinn fein my objective
is to win the support of people in
northern ireland to maintain
the dup and unionism as the largest
block in the northern ireland assembly
that's what i want to achieve and i
think in those circumstances we will
have a unionist first minister so what
do you say to people who would fear that
the dup will just use the protocol right
to prevent sharing power with sinn fein
i'm committed to devolution i am
committed to sharing power with other
parties in northern ireland
but we cannot go on with the situation
where the views and concerns of unionism
and unionist parties in northern are
being ignored i want to restore fairness
i want to restore respect i want to
restore political stability in northern
ireland but that means the protocol has
to be dealt with solutions need to be
found and the sooner that happens the
better and i hope that before the
assembly election david we will get an
agreement uh on uh dealing with the
problems and resolving uh the
difficulties created by this iris sea
border the ousting of arling foster
revealed division in the dup the parties
had three leaders unlike two first
ministers in the space of ten months is
the party in meltdown i don't think that
it is david we're
preparing for the election i've worked
hard since i became leader of the dup
and to heal the wounds
like every political party from time to
time
the dup has its differences
sadly last year those differences became
a very public affair
and i deeply regret that that happens
and i am working
to pull the party together and to get
the party into shape to fight the
election and win the election for
unionism sir geoffrey the founder of
this party the reverend ian paisley
would not have been impressed by boozy
parties in downing street
why is the dup the only opposition party
not calling for the prime minister's
resignation
well to be clear we have spoken out very
strongly
and i think that one of the most
passionate speeches that we've seen
in the house of commons was that of my
colleague jim shannon the member of
parliament for strangford who spoke
powerfully about the experience of his
family losing his mother-in-law
during the covert pandemic but i would
say this to the prime minister
northern ireland is an important part of
the united kingdom
you're our prime minister
and if you want to
build confidence
then
do what other prime ministers did in the
past recognize that we have a serious
problem here and instead of being
focused
on
what's going on in downing street be the
prime minister the people needs reach
out to northern ireland help us to
resolve these issues make this a
priority let's get
our political institutions restored on
the basis
of sound foundations that means dealing
with the protocol making these issues a
priority so that the people of northern
ireland
can enjoy strong stable government
that's what we expect of a prime
minister we can't go on like this david
we can't go on with the situation where
serious problems like we have here in
northern are not getting the attention
they deserve those are strong words from
a unionist party leader are you
suggesting that boris johnson
has made northern ireland such
a low priority that the peace process is
effectively being damaged i'm saying
that all of the controversy surrounding
um
downing street is making it difficult
for the prime minister to focus on what
needs to get priority i recognize the
situation for example in ukraine is
critical i recognize that getting the uk
out of uh covert and and into a more
normal situation and the recovery of our
economy and are supporting our health
service are important but so is northern
ireland and whilst i welcome very much
the commitment of liz trust um
to drive forward the negotiations it
disappoints me that our prime minister
cannot give a firm commitment
today
that if
there is not agreement reached uh with
the european union he will take the
steps that are necessary to restore
northern ireland's place within the uk
internal market that means triggering
article 16. that's the commitment i need
to get from this prime minister and if
he doesn't give it to you there's not
going to be a power sharing government
regardless of what happens during the
election well if the prime minister
um as i do cherishes the union
and i believe that the prime minister is
a unionist
then he needs to recognize that right
now northern ireland
there are
serious problems here that need to be
addressed i want the prime minister to
give that priority i want the prime
minister to give a firm commitment no
more words we need action here in
northern ireland sir jeffrey donaldson
thank you very much
steve barclay is the prime minister's
new chief of staff
he's already a minister and will now be
responsible for implementing the new
office of the prime minister
well it's all supposed to be a part of a
big clear out and reorganization at
number 10 in the wake of the partygate
scandal as the prime minister fights for
survival
so just how bad are things at number 10
and how will those that are left be
feeling
gavin barwell was theresa may's chief of
staff during some of the most turbulent
brexit years he joins me now
good morning lord barwell
now
given them
given that the prime minister was the
chief tormentor of your administration
uh can you tell me with a straight face
that you take no pleasure from his
present difficulties
yeah i can because i don't i don't take
any pleasure the difficulties that my
party is in at the moment and from the
point of view of the country uh you know
i don't think it's
anything anyone can take any pleasure
and at all trevor
uh no it's not not an out to shard and
freud no temptation to say i i told you
so because you did
right well so so there's a look i think
i'm we're perfectly entitled to warn uh
to say to people that the concerns that
we raised both about the brexit approach
the prime minister was going to take
you've just had an interview with
jeffrey donaldson there
uh teresa absolutely warned what a
border down the rsc might mean for our
politics so i think we're perfectly
entitled to take to say i told you so
but that's a different thing from what
you asked me which is do i take any
pleasure uh in seeing that the mess that
things are in the moment and i don't
okay well that's a very grown-up
approach um and of course that's why uh
the prime minister before previous prime
minister had you in there you were her
chief of staff um
steve barkley is your successor is that
a good appointment
so i've got a lot of time for steve i
think he's a really smart person
incredibly diligent uh he doesn't take
any nonsense he'll want high standards
there
i should declare an interest he's
someone i would consider a friend so
lots of good qualities that he has i
think that there are two challenges
the first is
he won't be able to do the job in the
way that i or nick timothy and fiona
hill or ed luellen or jonathan powell
did it because he's combining it with
being a government minister and an mp at
the same time so he's going to have to
find a way of doing the job in a
different way
and then the second challenge and i
think probably the key one
is whether the prime minister is going
to listen to the good advice that he
will give
you know a lot of the focus over the
last week or two has been about making
changes as downing street as if that
will
solve the problem it's worth
remembering that dan rosenfeld has just
announced he's standing down as chief of
staff he was brought in by the prime
minister to clear up the previous mess
in number 10. so there's only so much
different advisors can make
uh if the person at the top is not
actually listening to the advice that
we're given and to me
the most interesting thing about the
events of the last week or so
was mineira merza's letter where it was
made clear that actually the prime
minister was told
by his advisors
not to make that smear about kierstarma
last monday
and ignored that advice and a statement
that was meant to
show contrition and draw a line under
this story actually ended up making his
position so much worse
um just on on that point
um the business secretary just
a few minutes ago said to me that it
seemed a perfectly reasonable thing to
say in context
well i completely disagree with that i
mean if i if i imagine a high political
world where i had been advising boris
johnson before he went into the chamber
on monday
i would have said under no circumstances
either make any criticisms of your
opponents or make any excuses the job
today
is to go into the chamber and show
genuine contrition because that is your
only hope of drawing a line uh under
this story so i both think on an
intellectual level at a moral level what
he said was not acceptable i don't want
a politics there's enough there's enough
things trevor you'll know from the
people you interview there's enough
legitimate differences between us for
those to be the subject of political
debate and argument we don't want a
politics where people indulge in those
kind of smears but even if you set aside
that moral argument on a purely tactical
level it was a stupid thing for the
prime minister to do because it's led to
the resignation of one of his key aides
it's led to more letters more mps
submitting letters of no confidence in
him it's further
destabilized his position and the point
here is that he we know
he was given advice not to do that and
went ahead and did it anyway so what
that tells you is that yes having the
right people around you can help but
ultimately the culture in number 10 and
the decisions the government makes come
from the top and the prime minister
himself
if he's going to stay in office is going
to have to change the way he is behaving
and running the government
isn't the problem here then
i speak to you as an experienced advisor
that actually
he doesn't take advice and you could
have socrates machiavelli
and whoever else you liked in there uh
to advice him
but he when he's got it in his head
won't take that advice cannot help
himself and he will do what he wants
isn't the problem here it's not the
advisors not the circle around him it's
the prime minister so that that
definitely has been the problem and the
question is whether it's going to change
the other person that he's
bringing back into number uh bringing in
to number 10 is the new director of
communications good harry who was one of
his key advisors when he was mayor of
london so there was a period as you all
know from your own experience
when he was running london where first
with simon milton then with eddie lister
he had a team around him that he did
seem to to listen to and respect so it
is possible
uh that these changes you know he might
pay more attention to this new team than
he was to the previous one but you're
absolutely right about what the problem
has been up until now
uh it it
i don't want to take too much time on
this specific point but
every time
one of these things happens you know
he says there was no party oh yes there
was a party uh i wasn't another party oh
yes i was at the party uh
there's whatever it is about kirsten
somebody says
uh he's going to change he says it's
going to change and then he does it all
over again
yes i think
at some point in the future when
someone's writing a book about how to
handle political scandals the events of
the last few months will be like chapter
one of how not to do it
now if you imagine a hypothetical world
where when this story was first raised
number 10 had quickly established the
facts put them out there issued a
genuinely contrite apology
that might have been okay to get through
that what is indisputable
is that the way that the truth has been
dragged out of them
over the last two or three months has
made this situation far far worse far
more damaging to the prime minister's
reputation we're at a point today
where this where somewhere between 60
and 70
of your viewers think the prime minister
should resign
and ultimately
you know whatever comes out of the
police investigation or the final
version of the sue grey report if he
can't turn those numbers around if his
personal polling remains where it is
today then conservative mps are going to
make a change sooner or later
well well you've been you've been kind
enough to be one of our viewers today um
where are you on that uh which side of
that line are you on should he go as the
60 or 70 percent think
uh i think i'm not one of the
conservative p's they're going to make
the decision ultimately they're the
very difficult to defend the way in
which he has run number 10 and the way
in which he has tried to cover up what's
happened
and on the pragmatic test which your
viewers will probably have less sympathy
with about what's the right thing for
the conservative party to do i am very
skeptical
about whether it's going to be possible
for him to restore his standing up with
the british public so my inclination is
that the conservative party would be
better making a change
and i also think uh for the good of a
country in terms of trust and faith in
our politics there's a strong case for
change but it's not up to me to make a
decision ultimately this is a decision
uh that up until the next election at
least is one for conservative mps
well and it's a decision for him so if
you were his advisor
would you be saying
boris time's up i don't think there's uh
a chance in hell that the prime minister
is going to voluntarily resign he's
going to stay there
unless conservative mps remove him or
unless he loses an election uh and so
you know i i don't see any prospect of
him voluntarily standing downtrend
gavin barwell thank you so much for your
time and your uh experience this morning
my pleasure
now understand your opponent and their
psychology sage advice for anyone in a
high-stakes negotiation
certainly if taking part in talks with
russia over ukraine and the hundred
thousand troops moscow sent to the
border but do we really know what drives
vladimir putin and what he hopes to
achieve by his actions in the region
well i sat down with a man who knows him
only too well mikhail kordekovsky was
once russia's richest oligarch until
putin imprisoned him
now he lives in exile here in london
you have sat opposite vladimir putin
and you've paid
a price for opposing him
what kind of person are we dealing with
here
putin is
the president what's it strong
[Music]
so why do you think
he
and the
people who surround him
the clique i guess you would call it
um
what do they think they're doing
in ukraine
let me
come to ukraine specifically
in a moment but
just on putin
the person that you are describing
uh there's only one word that comes to
my mind you're saying this is a paranoid
person
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
let me
ask about what we could do to deter
him
if it can't be done
from
inside russia or ukraine then it's up to
the rest of the world
now one thing
that could be done is to put pressure
on the clique around him
now when you came to london you had had
to give up your assets
but
there are many of the putin clique who
have for example property
in london they have their assets here
what people
call dirty money
could we be doing more
to put pressure on him and the people
around him
by essentially
seizing or
interrupting their access
to that money in london
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
well that's it from this show for today
uh after the break we'll have insight
from sam coates uh in the take
uh today we are celebrating certainly
the most famous woman probably the most
famous person in the world and her
seventh year of accession
but perhaps it's uh worth signing off to
say that maybe the second most famous
woman in the world lata mangeshkar the
bollywood bollywood's favorite singer
record 30 000 songs
died at 92 remarkable voice
see you next week